[Aplausos]
[Música]
méxico ha sufrido tanta corrupción
política y durante tanto tiempo que ha
provocado que hoy un líder como andrés
manuel lópez obrador ante el premio visa
polític 2021 sea un político muy popular
a pesar de todos los suspensos que ha
cosechado en sus pocos años al frente
del gobierno hablo no es el típico
populista que grita e insulta pero sí
que tiene muy afinada la que quizás es
la cualidad más importante de todo buen
político sabe ofrecer a los ciudadanos
mexicanos exactamente lo que más quieren
en cada momento que los anteriores
presidentes vivían a todo trapo pues
hablo lo tiene claro viajar en clase
turista convertir la residencia
presidencial de los pinos en una especie
de centro cultural y prescindir del 787
presidencial con el cual por cierto
parece que nadie sabe muy bien qué
demonios hacer el caso es que decisiones
de este estilo despiertan la simpatía
popular y no me malinterpretéis muchas
de estas cosas pueden estar bien sobre
todo si tenemos en cuenta el lujoso tren
de vida que caracteriza a los
presidentes y altos políticos mexicanos
pero el problema viene cuando con estas
cosas se pretende justificar toda la
donde el gobierno y es pero aún cuando
se persigue que el apoyo popular
cosechado sirva para tapar que la
economía vaya a regular o que la gestión
de la pandemia fuera mala el caso es que
pese a los altísimos índices de
criminalidad la economía renqueante y la
pandemia lópez obrador mantiene un nivel
de aprobación muy alto entre los
electores mexicanos tan alto como los
palos que seguro seguro nos van a caer
por este vídeo
queridos amigos amigas lópez obrador es
popularmente conocido como hablo para
abreviar claro que que no abre vía es el
propio amplio prácticamente todos los
días y para mayor gloria del presidente
se hace para el mismo dar ruedas de
prensa que se extienden por más de dos
horas y la pregunta es es que acaso el
presidente de un país como méxico no
tiene nada mejor que hacer pues parece
ser que no fijamos la guerra
es sinónimo
d
[Música]
i
y racionalidad seis palabras en 19
segundos si es que con ruedas de prisa
tan largas a veces después ya no sabes
ni qué decir pero porque visual política
hablamos en esta ocasión de ambos
escritos amigos amigas no bajéis la
guardia ante este abuelito afable y
cuando quiere también simpático y hasta
enternecedor y digo que no bajes la
guardia porque la presidencia de anv lo
está llevando a cabo lo que se conoce
como la cuarta transformación de méxico
o un plan político que consiste en poner
punto y final derogar derribar las
reformas de sus predecesores para poner
en marcha sus propias iniciativas en
todo tipo de campos
y el problema es que las iniciativas de
anv no tiene mucho que ver con las
típicas políticas latinoamericanas que
una y otra y otra vez han demostrado
fallidas y que pueden terminar por
orientar la inversión productiva eso es
precisamente lo que está pasando por
ejemplo con el sector energético en dos
ámbitos muy claros por un lado está la
reforma eléctrica por otro el rumbo que
ha tomado la petrolera estatal pemex
bajo esta presidencia y sabéis que es la
reforma energética de habló a la que
queremos echar un vistazo en este vídeo
que está pasando en el sector petrolero
de mexico en qué consiste la reforma
eléctrica de habló y lo que es más
importante cómo puede afectar todas
estas medidas a la economía de este país
hoy en visual político vamos a responder
a todas estas preguntas pero antes vamos
a ver un poco de historia
el monopolio estatal
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas hace justo un
siglo méxico era el segundo mayor
productor de petróleo del mundo tan solo
por detrás de los eeuu en aquel momento
el sector estaba dominado por las
compañías extranjeras por ejemplo la
antaño dominante compañía mexicana el
águila había sido adquirida por la anglo
holandesa royal dax él también había un
montón de compañías estadounidenses que
operaban a el sur de la frontera pero
sin embargo pronto perdieron el interés
en los yacimientos mexicanos los
ingleses comenzaron a explotar el
petróleo en oriente medio y los
estadounidenses en venezuela y es que
veréis el problema para estas compañías
es que el movimiento obrero era uno de
los pilares sobre los que se apoyaba el
presidente lázaro cárdenas cuando
llegaron las petroleras no tenía ni la
más remota idea de lionel que se estaban
metiendo
un conflicto laboral saltó en 1938 a la
arena política cuando las petroleras
intentaron no acatar una sentencia de la
suprema corte a favor de las demandas de
los trabajadores al intentar evitar
cumplir con el fallo las compañías
extranjeras vieron como un asunto
laboral se convirtió en toda una disputa
sobre la soberanía de la nación así que
el presidente lázaro cárdenas intervino
directamente en el asunto decretando la
nacionalización de la industria
petrolera tres meses después cárdenas
decretó la creación de petróleos
méxicanos pemex la empresa estatal que
recibía el monopolio para explotar y
administrar los yacimientos del petróleo
del país
la jugada a méxico pareció salirle de
perlas porque pues digamos que los años
40 eeuu y el reino unido- tenían otras
preocupaciones mucho más importantes que
pasarle la factura méxico no nos parece
además la segunda guerra mundial y el
crecimiento económico de la posguerra
incrementaron considerablemente la
demanda de crudo con lo que la
nacionalización se convirtió en un gran
negocio y ojo porque el petrolero no fue
el único ámbito energético intervenido
por el presidente cárdenas antes ya
había sido el turno del sector eléctrico
[Música]
en 1937 cárdenas fundó la cee efe y la
comisión federal de electricidad su
propósito era operar en el sector sin
ánimo de lucro basándose exclusivamente
en principios técnicos
el objetivo era obtener el mayor
rendimiento posible al mínimo coste esto
hizo que las compañías privadas sólo se
interesaran por las zonas más rentables
las principales ciudades y las zonas
industrializadas así que para la
comisión federal de electricidad
quedaron las áreas rurales y dispersas
[Música]
evidentemente este sistema no funcionó
era una ruina para la empresa estatal y
encima a más de la mitad de los
mexicanos seguían sin suministro
eléctrico así que qué solución creéis
que adoptó el gobierno de mexico a ver
quizás liberalizar el mercado favorecer
la competencia o incentivar la inversión
por ejemplo pues no para nada nada de
eso en 1960 el presidente adolfo lópez
mateos completó la nacionalización del
sector eléctrico y sabéis que en un
primer momento pues tampoco pareció
salir les mal méxico tenía recursos más
que suficientes como para hacer frente a
las malas decisiones y mantener enormes
subsidios al consumo de electricidad
pensaba que los países con petróleo eran
los nuevos ricos del panorama
internacional y más aún a partir de los
años 70
la crisis del petróleo de 1973 y de 1979
dispararon el precio del crudo
multiplicando los ingresos de pemex por
sus exportaciones además en
1979 comenzó a operar el complejo
cantarell uno de los mayores yacimientos
del mundo el problema es que los
gobiernos mexicanos tenían el control
completo sobre la petrolera y no la
dirigían con una mentalidad empresarial
todo lo contrario la exprimían con
múltiples impuestos y regalías con los
que nutrir las arcas del estado lo que
dejó a pemex con muchos menos recursos
para invertir y crecer
[Música]
el complejo cantarell alcanzan su pico
de producción en el 2004 aquel año fue
también el de mayor producción de toda
la historia de pemex 3,4 millones de
barriles diarios de crudo desde entonces
desde entonces ha caído en picado
ejercicio tras ejercicio hasta situarse
en algo menos de la mitad claro que ante
el declive de cantarell el remedio fue
casi peor que la enfermedad pemex
invirtió 70 mil millones de dólares
entre los años 2008 y 2012 en la
exploración y producción de crudo el
problema amigos es que la mayor parte de
lo invirtió en áreas para las que pemex
pues estaba técnicamente mal preparada
como la perforación en aguas profundas o
el fracc es decir el desastre estaba
garantizado para colmo las inversiones
hicieron fundamentalmente con deuda
porque el gobierno mexicano pues no
estaba dispuesto a dejar de recibir sus
cheques así que la crisis de pemex
agudizó con estas malas decisiones de
inversión
[Música]
y si luego a todo esto le sumamos la
corrupción que dominó la compañía
durante décadas y una toma de decisiones
de corte más política que empresarial
que por ejemplo hizo que la petrolera
tuviera una plantilla mucho más grande
de lo que hubiera sido necesario lo que
nos encontramos es precisamente con una
petrolera endeudada hasta las cejas y
con una producción menguante amigos la
joya de méxico estaba a punto de caer y
para evitarlo estaba claro que había que
cambiar muchas pero que muchas cosas y
esa papeleta le tocó ni más ni menos que
uno de los gobiernos más manchados por
corrupción y peor valorados de toda la
historia del país que el de enrique peña
nieto- así que claro dará igual lo que
se hiciera cualquier medida quedaría
manchada incluso aunque la reforma fuese
en buena dirección
la reforma energética de 2013 acabó con
el monopolio estatal de pemex sobre el
sector petrolero abriéndolo a la
inversión privada se permitió que las
empresas extranjeras pujarán en subastas
transparentes retransmitidas online por
hacerse con la explotación y producción
de campos petroleros también se abrió el
camino a reducir el número de
trabajadores de pemex que ha pasado de
151 mil empleados en 2013 a los 120.000
de la actualidad se completaron nueve
subastas petroleras hasta que se
paralizaron en julio de 2018 cuando amlo
ganó las elecciones
y el balance a día de hoy es que en
aquella subasta se adjudicaron 111
campos y 34 hoy e iniciaron su
explotación hasta el momento se han
invertido 18 mil millones de dólares la
renta petrolera del estado mexicano
establecida en los contratos es de
aproximadamente un 74% lo que supone uno
de los mayores porcentajes de todo el
mundo
qué quiere decir esto pues básicamente
que la reforma trajo multimillonarias
inversiones de empresas extranjeras
compañías privadas que arriesgan su
dinero en explorar y extraer el petróleo
pero que luego le pagan al estado
mexicano la mayor parte de los ingresos
derivados de su producción todo ello sin
que el gobierno mexicano invierta un
solo peso parece un buen business no
creéis pues amigos como siempre hay
alguien que no está del todo de acuerdo
así se pronunciaba habló cuando era el
líder de la oposición si nos quitan el
petróleo
sería
como desangrar
a méjico anv lo planteó una oposición
feroz contra la reforma energética de
peña nieto como buen populista de llegó
a prometer que haría un referéndum para
que el pueblo se pronunciara sobre la
misma pero amigos una cosa es la
política y otra muy distinta gobernar en
diciembre del año 2018 amlo tomaba
posesión como presidente de mexico es
decir que ha pasado tiempo más que
suficiente para empezar a ver qué está
pasando con la política energética de
este presidente así que atentos
[Música]
gasolina
[Aplausos]
y
lópez obrador ha hecho consultas
populares de todo tipo para ver si
construye una línea ferroviaria o un
aeropuerto pero la consulta prometida
sobre qué hacer con la reforma
energética bueno pues no esa quedó en el
olvido claro que eso no ha evitado que
pemex sigue siendo un quebradero de
cabeza para el gobierno de mexico porque
aunque hablo hable de la petrolera
estatal como si fuera la joya de la
corona la realidad es muy pero que muy
diferente los años pasan y las pérdidas
se acumulan para pemex algo difícil de
entender cuando extraen un barril de
crudo le cuesta una media de siete
dólares y lo vende por diez veces más
claro que luego el estado mexicano aqsiq
sea pemex con impuestos pensad que un
tercio de todo el gasto público del país
azteca es sostenido por los recursos
extraídos de la petrolera estatal y si a
eso le sumamos que el resto de negocios
de pemex pues son una auténtica ruina no
nos sorprende noticias como estas pemex
entre las diez compañías más endeudadas
del planeta hablamos ni más ni menos que
de una deuda de más de cien mil millones
de dólares una deuda que además no para
de marcar cada poco tiempo nuevos
registros históricos
[Música]
así que lópez obrador se ha puesto manos
a la obra para reflotar la petrolera
estatal y lo primero que hizo amlo fue
aprobar una nueva ley de hidrocarburos
con el propósito de favorecer a pemex en
el mercado de las estaciones de servicio
luego respecto a la apertura a la
inversión extranjera en los campos
petroleros mexicanos habló apostó por
revisar los contratos ya adjudicados
para comprobar si hubo o no corrupción
además como ya hemos visto se
suspendieron las subastas petroleras
desde el mismo momento en que ganó las
elecciones y recientemente lo más
peligroso para el país es que el
gobierno a escribir un paso más allá y
ha actuado directamente contra los
intereses de un consorcio que ya ha
invertido más de 300 millones de dólares
en el país y que está encabezado por la
petrolera estadounidense talos en el ine
el resultado es que estas medidas lanzan
un mensaje muy negativo hacia los
inversores y todo para que pues para
beneficiar a los mismos de siempre el
mayor hallazgo privado de petróleo de
méxico será operado por la estatal pemex
de momento y a pesar de todo el
resultado es que cuando este presidente
llegó al poder la empresa petrolera
mexicana producía alrededor de 1,8
millones de barriles hoy la cifra está
en torno a los 16 millones y todo apunta
a que las cosas pues no a mejorar mucho
[Música]
luego si hay algo que sorprende de la
economía mexicana es que un país que
tiene tantos yacimientos de petróleo se
vio obligado a importar combustibles
porque sus refinerías son de los tiempos
de pancho villa' se trata de una
anomalía que amlo se ha propuesto
resolver el problema es que la factura
está acumulando demasiados ceros de
momento se han invertido más de 6.000
millones en modernizar las refinerías de
la petrolera estatal y en comprar a ser
la mitad de una refinería en texas cuya
propiedad estaba compartida con pemex lo
cual pues si lo pensáis no tiene mucho
sentido para que poner fin a una
sociedad consell que ha funcionado
también cuando pemex gestiona mucho peor
sus propias activos más en fin
cuestiones de la política pero esperad
un momento porque eso prácticamente no
es nada si lo comparamos con los casi
nueve mil millones de dólares que aún no
se está gastando en uno de sus proyectos
estrella construir una refinería en su
estado natal de tabasco habló no quiere
que nada se interponga entre pemex y la
autosuficiencia de méxico para producir
combustibles y cuando decimos nada os
aseguro que es nada
está construyendo una refinería en un
espacio natural que prometió proteger la
cuestión es que el gobierno mexicano
está ahora mismo poniendo toda la carne
en el asador para que el país produzca
todos los combustibles que consume para
el año 2023 el problema amigos es que
tal y como hemos visto lo hace siguiendo
una receta muy similar a la que méxico
ha seguido años atrás petróleo
nacionalismo y mucho intervencionismo
sin tener excesivamente en cuenta los
criterios empresariales bien todo esto
sobre el petróleo pero qué ocurre con el
otro brazo de la reforma energética qué
demonios pasa con el sector eléctrico
pues acentos
la reforma constitucional
la nacionalización de 1960 convirtió al
sector eléctrico en un monopolio estatal
en manos de la comisión federal de
electricidad así fue hasta los años 90
cuando se produjo una tímida apertura
del sector privado se puso en marcha el
llamado modelo de auto abasto un
mecanismo que permitirá a las empresas
esquivar a la comisión y comprar
electricidad a plantas de generación de
compañías eléctricas privadas en una
fórmula similar a los pp us es decir los
contratos de compraventa de energía el
caso es que la apertura al sector
privado cobró mucha fuerza con la
reforma energética de peña nieto que
impulsó la inversión en generación
eléctrica se estableció por ejemplo un
mercado mayorista de electricidad que
daba prioridad a los proveedores de
energía más baratos y renovables suena
bastante bien verdad pues para hablo no
como peña nieto- relevo a la comisión
federal de electricidad a la pf a un
segundo plano habló dedicó buena parte
de sus esfuerzos durante el 2021 a poner
en marcha una reforma eléctrica que
reforzará a la comisión se hace al
propio gobierno
la reforma eléctrica de anv lo causó
gran polémica al cambiar el orden de
despacho de energía por parte de las
centrales en primer lugar entrarían en
funcionamiento las hidroeléctricas y las
centrales de fuel y carbón de la cee efe
en segundo lugar los ciclos combinados
de gas que generan su energía para la
comisión tras esas plantas se daría paso
a los parques privados de energía eólica
y solar y por último los ciclos
combinados de gas de compañías privadas
pero vamos a ver a quién se le ocurre
dar prioridad a las térmicas sobre las
renovables la energía eólica y la solar
tiene que funcionar pues cuando hay sol
y viento y cuando no lo hay pues es
cuando pones a funcionar las térmicas y
no pues todo el tinglado no tiene mucho
sentido de primero de sistema eléctrico
el caso es que lópez obrador aprobó esta
reforma hace ya meses pero un tribunal
la paralizó claro que si pensáis que se
iba a detener al presidente mexicano
estáis muy pero que muy equivocados el
presidente de mexico amenaza con un
cambio constitucional si se anula la ley
energética y como decimos por aquí dicho
y hecho
[Música]
el problema a priori del presidente
mexicano es que no dispone de la mayoría
suficiente para poder aprobar esta
reforma y ahora ya no se habla del orden
de despacho sino de cuotas se pretende
garantizar que las centrales de la fefe
produzcan un 54 por ciento de la
electricidad de méxico y ahora os
preguntaréis a qué viene tanto empeño en
ese porcentaje pues básicamente a que en
2020 entró en vigor una nueva regulación
internacional que limita el azufre del
combustible que utilizan las navieras
hasta entonces este era uno de los
principales mercados para el fuel que
producen las refinerías de pemex tan
obsoletas que se han mostrado incapaces
de reducir sus niveles de azufre así que
este es el objetivo de anv lo poner a
las térmicas de la cee efe a quemar el
fuego que nadie le quiere comprar la
petrolera mexicana todo ello aunque
contamine mucho más y sus costes de
generación sean para como un 25 por
ciento superiores a los de las nuevas
plantas renovables es decir que hablo le
da igual que méxico produzca energía más
cara o más sucia lo único que le
preocupa es reflotar a las empresas
estatales mexicanas al precio que sea y
si al final eso significa aumentar los
subsidios para que nos suban la factura
de la luz pues nada a tirar de la
chequera y aun con todo esto no es lo
peor fijaos
[Música]
con la reforma de amlo méxico no solo
tendrá energía más cara y más sucia sino
que además viendo el panorama peligran
inversiones por valor de 40.000 millones
de dólares en energía eólica y solar
todo esto resulta preocupante para el
futuro de méxico porque se suma al bajón
que está sufriendo las inversiones desde
que amlo ganó las elecciones lo que
puede terminar convirtiéndose en una
oportunidad perdida ahora que las
multinacionales están buscando
diversificar sus cadenas de suministro
fuera de china pero es que los
inversores no se fían del presidente
mexicano los datos hablan por sí solos
[Música]
en fin ya veis cómo están las cosas por
méxico pero llegó hasta aquí turno para
ti ves bien que se prioricen los
intereses de las empresas públicas sobre
la instalación de renovables si os
parecen las reformas emprendidas por anv
lo podéis dejarnos vuestras respuestas
por aquí abajo en los comentarios y como
siempre existe vídeos el resulta
interesante no olvidéis darle a like
inscribiros a visual político una vez
más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]